hi guys I'm Greg Alba and I'm John
Humphrey we are gonna do our Avengers
end game spoiler talk over there but
before we move over there I wanted to
give a quick shout outs of today's video
sponsor which is amino apps John show
them the phone what this phone weed
recommended the Marvel amino a few times
on this channel and now that the end
game is here it's the perfect place to
discuss all things Marvel with fans from
across the world if you're not familiar
amino is a massive network of online
communities and message boards for fans
and creators alike whether you're into
Marvel supernatural Game of Thrones or
anything else really chances are there's
a community of like-minded people on
Amino the app allows you to post blogs
and polls chat live share fan art
compete across leaderboards and a whole
lot more and now Amina's getting even
better thanks to their new amino stories
feature watch' fans are creators alike
share their thoughts and creativity
through fast and fun in-app videos we
actually just posted one about our dream
Avengers teams and you can do to down
the app for free on Android or iOS
simply just click the link below in the
description box or the pin comment and
follow the instructions once you've got
the app you can search and join the
Marvel amino and don't forget to follow
us at real rejects don't rejects
that's right don't forget to follow us
at real rejects all one word now let's
hop into those spoilers now shall we
alright now that we moved over here
let's move on to that spoiler talk hmm
so we saw this twice and when I was on
the John Campea show but something about
this on our community page that I put on
Twitter
that's a Greg L book when I was on John
Campea show one of the questions he
asked is like where would I rank this
and I really emphasize that I feel like
I need to watch this twice before I rank
this I had a feeling but often times or
movies that I've loved out of the MCU
that when I want rewatch I'm like first
time this movie undoubtably is my
favorite Marvel movie I can talk for
hours we're not going to but I can I can
talk for many many hours
about just why I think this is the best
movie and we're gonna break we're gonna
go through it on I guess the thing is I
can go through like literally every
single moment so who we have is bullet
points for act 1 act 2 act 3 and we'll
you know we'll go through all the big
stuff that goes on in it but I I really
love it because of the fact that it's
it's tone in more than just like cool
fanservice
it just seems so damn well-constructed
it blows my mind how well they stuck the
landing to the point of not only did it
meet my expectations but somehow it
completely surpassed my expectations and
I can't think of out of all these 22
films of an MCU film that has such an
emotional punch throughout this whole
this whole film there's so much emotions
generated like I've cried so many
different times and I also love the
pacing of it of how it just slowly
starts and just builds and builds and
builds and then you get to the big
finale action and then before that big
finale there's there's barely any action
before that in like in terms of like
fight scenes there's only a couple I can
really think of and they're very
short-lived so I'm just I'm so blown
away by this and I think John and I are
pretty much on the same page sit down
and rank all the Marvel's would be kind
of an undertaking but um yeah I think
this is definitely one of there for me
most distinct movies definitely one that
just pulled me in and had me from
beginning to end and where it's weird
because there's so much hype and
expectations attached to this movie and
it has such a landing to stick and so I
it's funny to me because it made me
forget about my expectations while I was
watching it and I think that that's a
special thing to have happen and
especially in a time where it's easy to
be cynical and easy to predict these
kinds of things it's a movie that gave
me as many surprises as
yeah and and yeah I kind of got what I
was hoping for along with a bunch of
really wonderful gifts along the way and
yeah like you said it is a very
emotional story because it really hones
in to the impact that all of this is
having on the characters and the true
heroism in the face of major defeat and
so yeah I think this definitely is
perhaps the most Marvel Cinematic
Universe Marvel movie best
representation of what the MCU is it III
don't really like that criticism with
any MCU movie of well the the one
negative to it is you need to have seen
these other Marvel movies in order to
understand it I'm like that's kind of
the point of what makes the MCU such a
special thing that other franchises have
the hardest time replicating with
cinematic universe building and I just
to me I'm like if this was a show this
would be the best if this was the season
finale to a show this would be the best
episode and so going into it starting
off with act 1 like right away from the
opening scene of Hawkeye yeah the reason
I really appreciate this opening so much
because it's more than just we got to
reestablish the decimation you know it's
more than that and it's more than what
was Hawkeye up to it's showing the very
human level of loss of the people who
had zero clue of what the hell is going
on like because in the end of infinity
war you know you're seeing this a giant
chaotic battle and everyone was trying
to kill Thanos and he suddenly snaps and
all the characters who've been tuning in
with this whole time are starting to
vanish and disappear and sure we get
like a nugget of a post-credits scene
with Maria hill and Nick Fury but this
moment really puts you in the human
drama the human level of there's just
this family having a good day and then
suddenly what the [ __ ] happening
almost Twilight Zone II little
because it is sweet and it isn't
endearing just life
slice em hmm then ya brings you back
into the steaks and a completely
different tone and and yeah it makes a
wonderful little prologue for the movie
and especially after the big deal they
made about like where was hot guy where
was ant-man like this movie uses those
aspects really well I thought and to
join back up with Clint as you know his
family dusts really is heartbreaking
it's the perfect opening for me that
every one of these really meanwhile it's
it's one of the one of the things I love
about this movie so much is everything
felt so well thought out that they
thought what is most necessary at this
point and what is most like what scene
is most necessary what's necessary to
put into see yeah I love that and then
going into like Captain Marvel saving
Tony and nebula but even before that you
know you're with Tony and nebula they
had them killing the time what they're
playing like the football game with the
paper football game yeah I really love
the tone established that it was from
the first trailer when you see the Iron
Man helmet when you're watching the
movie you're like wow we're really just
looking at this helmet for a while you
know little things like that are things
I really appreciate with this film of
how much time they're going to take with
each scene and let it really breathe
that really feel that isolated
environment and that feeling of loss and
so yeah when he's gonna give that
message and also with their dynamics
it's kind of cool visual storytelling
instead of having to do a lot of you
know what's the rapport been like you
like you just you get one moment where
they're playing or they're playing paper
football and then you get another moment
where nebula is you know talking Tony
into a seat so he can sleep a little bit
better because they think they're gonna
die their ship has run out of gas at
this point you know yeah well even
though I didn't pick it up in the
trailer but even the way that Tony is
just so frail which is what would happen
to you a not eating and you know
drinking much but also in space you know
like your muscles start to deteriorate
and you atrophy and stuff like that yeah
and and they'd really they really do a
good job of putting you in the shoes of
these moments they let them breathe yeah
I think also with Captain Moore
saving Tony that that makes a lot of
sense you know it's not just like I was
finding the press screening no one
collect but an opening night audiences
everyone clapped yeah when that moment
comes that like people appreciated
Captain Marvel more on opening night
yeah and I think with the post-credits
scene at Captain Marvel and it kind of
just makes sense to me when you think
about it with rocket and that's his ship
that he would probably have some way of
at least tracking his ship but it's so
far away that they probably can't get to
it
you know so I like when Captain Marvel's
saves him but even right there in that
gritty drama of when captain of when
Iron Man were you nights with the team
you know kisses pepper and he's like
with he's with cap knees like I lost
again because Lee in Civil War he lost a
cab and then he loses the Thanos here
and when he's just sort of breaking down
the next day when he's on the IV you
know that whole moment I find it funny
how there was that whole vision sequence
not the character vision but the age of
Ultron where he has that vision you know
everybody did yeah hi only because this
movie wants to wrap up everything yeah
how they like that was one of the things
that when I first watched I'm like oh
[ __ ] they acknowledged a rewatch you're
like okay that's all they needed to do I
guess we just acknowledge it's really
sir that's not what happened like the
vision that took place is not what
happens in this movie or even an
infinity war is kind of a romanticized
vision yes definitely and then when they
go to kill thanos that moment I've
noticed there's been a lot of people who
feel very much in conflict with when
Thanos is killed because I like when you
catch up with him how he's just living
the farmer life you know and on a
rewatch I noticed even other little
nuggets that I just didn't catch up on
before like when he first starts walking
up the stairs to his home he's limping
oh yeah and then when they show up and
then
what you know when they're fighting him
and then they find out about the stuff
that oh she used the stones to
obliterate the stones I am inevitable
yeah yeah and then Thor goes for the
head chopped off his head but it both
both times we have what we've watched it
the crowd gasps because you're like
that's not what I expected yeah yeah
that scene had a very distinct writing
flair to me because I noticed they they
said we're going to kill thanos and they
pointedly both amputate his hand and
then behead him and it's one of the more
I think directly overtly violent things
that has happened in a marble movie well
that's one of the they're these you know
with the violent spirit that's one other
Star Wars callback so they do in a lot
of their Marvel films is the the
chopping off the hand but within the
context of this you don't think back to
that Marvel thing that they do to pay
tribute to Star Wars because they're
thinking of the affinity golly that's on
his hand but when people gasp because
and then then you do this five years
later jump and from talking with people
on notice people have had different
responses to it some people found like
oh gosh is this gonna be a disappointing
film like the fact that we're doing like
that oh just kill off in the beginning
for me personally when they kill off
Thanos right away what I'm like what the
[ __ ] and then they do five years later
my first thought and I think I said this
out loud in the press training was this
is so cool because this is gonna be
nothing like what I thought it was gonna
be as I really thought we were just
gonna be I like this badass movie maybe
with some time-travel evolved to get the
stoats they could have gone with versus
Infinity Gauntlet at the end but I
thought it was just gonna be a movie
about them gearing up so they can take
down Santos in the end you get that
finale battle and then when you do have
five years later jump I was i I it's
hard for heaven temple chills from like
that that was so unexpected you know
it'd be one thing if it was like a month
later or even six months later but five
years means damn these characters
they're gonna be so different yeah lived
in the after meds it's the to them this
is just the way the world is now yeah
you even get that a cameo from Joe Russo
and there
at the meeting of people coping one
another and people were like clapping
and stuff and laughing so hard just
because he was there that I'd even pick
up on that oh this is the subtle
dialogue he's a gay character I don't
know I'm like cool we got a gay
character here it's Joe Russo yeah and
and then when ant-man comes back I like
that you see that's the thing that five
years later gap makes a big difference
because if this was a month later six
months later or whatever the whole thing
with the rat going over the control
system in order to open up the the
quantum realm vortex thing in the van I
feel like that would have just felt like
being a lot less it's still convenient
that the rat was able to trigger the you
know bring him back sequence but I will
say yeah the five years does make the
the likelihood of a rat turning on the
machine a lot more plausible yeah
because it wasn't just like oh he did
this at the right time when a man
returns in him trying to you know figure
out what the hell's going on with the
world and and when he goes - what does
it say the vanished and all the vanished
yeah he's looking at the monuments like
where's cat is cats please not cats he's
calling when he reunites with Cassie
Lang and she's older that every time the
both times I've seen it that really
makes me cry he like that showcases just
how natural Paul Rudd can be because
like there's yeah when they're on the
porch together there's so little
dialogue in it and it holds you at bated
breath because I'm like how how is this
moment gonna wrap and it's the perfect
you're so big like it's one of that's
perfectly bittersweet life moments yeah
and I love that this movie takes so much
time for those oh absolutely
it's a beautiful scene this is a very
very beautiful scene and I also also
really picked up on this the second time
we watched it when you cut back to Black
Widow and she's talking with like a coy
a Captain Marvel with a new haircut you
know like hey what's the status of
everything like that I love that moment
when he's talking with Rhodey
about all these cartel people are dead
they know it's Clint and you just see
these tears in her eyes you have just
how much she really cares so much about
him and how big she is see him go down
yeah the thing I picked up on the second
time was the foreshadowing moment when
Black Widow says when when cap is
sitting down with her and says we both
need to get a life and she says you
first and then funny nothing will go
more until later but you know Black
Widow dies in this movie yeah and then
cap is the one who gets a life brilliant
the other thing across the board that
just gets more rewarding about this film
on a second viewing is that so many
jokes dovetail around you know and
there's so many little moments are
called back to or paid off in ways that
are not in your face but rather clever
and that are well well timed yeah true
you know going with the whole time
machine element I love when time iced I
love when these movies just acknowledge
you know what this one bothered to set
up a different set of time-travel
mechanics to work off of I mean I don't
know what theoretical science they may
or may not be based on but yeah that
whole scene where they acknowledge a
whole bunch of other moves yeah don't
think of the time-travel like all of
these well or a constant people to this
day or the weekend people after seeing
the movie people or people still get
confused and the movie really went out
of its way to try to say it's not this
rule but people still do get confused
and I for me I was surprisingly wasn't
confused and I normally in the situation
like this I would be confused but to me
it just sort of feels like alternate
timelines and that it's just one it's
hard to explain I'm not gonna try to
explain it you configure but when you
catch up with Tony and his daughter
Morgan oh yeah I love that see that five
year gap allows for organic growth after
all this if this literally if this all
of us thought it I'd be like six months
later or something no one expected five
years but that five years makes such a
huge difference in terms of how everyone
is that for all these people to be so
different at this point may
that much more sense because we've got
time to live with their that are lived
in this world post like decimation right
they've gotten used to just accepted
this reality yeah and and the
psychological ramifications that come
with it you know and I like I like the
dynamics that Tony has with his daughter
you know yeah it's very adorable you
know she's not exactly like the most
later daughter in the world but it's not
about that's more about Tony's yeah
there's a sweet gentle moment I Love You
3000 I say it's a John every night
and that's another thing I as we talk
about this movie I'm sure we'll be going
into it a little bit more but the
foreshadowing of Tony like not
foreshadowing but the setting up that
Tony's going to die because if you look
back at the first Ironman and how he's
always grown Tony Stark
he started off as this is very insanely
selfish narcissistic dude who was a
Playboy you know slip sorry I'm a woman
and everything and then when you see him
in this movie he's he's married he's
retired he's not living in the mansion
billionaire life signee more he sell
down on this life house by a lake he's
got a family he's got a daughter he's so
changed and that his whole arc here is
how he grows to be completely selfless
and I love that element here and even
with Tony and pepper talking with one
another and when he after he figures out
the time travel element how he says how
she doesn't even try to argue with him
about it oh yeah been trying to get you
to stop and I like that scene as well
for the small notes of it because the
whole thing about and I think you
touched upon it was his ability to rest
he's like she says to him you know if
you you know put it in a safe and drop
it to the bottom of the lake and go to
bed and forget about it will you be able
to rest you know would you be able to
let that off your mind right that comes
back at the end and it's just there so
you pick up on so many great - about the
foreshadowing is that you watch it the
first time and the foreshadowing I think
in my opinion is done with enough
finesse that the first time you know
it's there in certain instances but
don't know exactly where it's pointing
you and then the second time you watch
it you really see these subtle ways in
which each little bit of foreshadowing
is guiding you along through the story
and it's it's it's really well we're
just in act 1 right and the thing is I
don't feel like going into I've never
felt so compelled to go so into depth
about it yeah I have Marvel movie before
yeah and then you know getting to
Professor Hulk like who has the bigger
brand then every comm professor hulking
here but it's so obvious a you know
inspired by the professor Hulk element
oh and that was such a treat Mark
Ruffalo's the way his Hulk has just
consistently evolved yes in this
franchise is great from um that's my
secret cap I'm always angry too broody
Hulk and then too from thor ragnarok
yeah and then going into this version of
the Hulk you see if this was six months
later or something or even a year this
probably wouldn't have felt so right but
because it's five years you're like oh
you probably had time to figure out how
to have this happen I think the CGI on
him is incredible yeah I'm never
distracted by it I'm never pulled out
there are times where you got such close
ups on him that I swear it's practical
oh you know another fun thing about this
kind of movie because this is a flagship
everything is going to be firing at top
notches and not all of the effects are
seamless but that's kind of the fun part
to me once I step back is going wow like
things like Professor hope that just
looks so photo-real yeah so convincing
and yeah like and that have the texture
of skin and all that stuff and I love
the gentle giant element to him yeah and
that moment I think the second time
worked a lot better jumping ahead in the
third act when he's like mocking because
he's so funny in there or even the
moment with it because this movie as
much as I love the emotional depth and
here the humor really hits there's a lot
of it and you know that moment where
rocket and nebula show up and tacos fly
out of em
like copy just has the shell hood
everything just leaves the dock that
transitional baby that was almost just
like a little comic strip plot because
it's just a perfect bit yes like and and
then also when I went because a big part
of like Professor Hulk when he shows up
but he just gives me the to just walks
off movies could be like Bruce is at
peace like it's so great I feel like
Mark Ruffalo just had the most fun doing
this yeah you could feel it and I like
how he looked like Mark Ruffalo - he
didn't just look like the Hulk I like
that it was a good blend of Hulk meat
because that's the whole point of the
character that it is Bruce Banner meets
Hulk all merge into one that was great
and of course you know when they're like
riding on the back of the truck with a
rocket oh god the spark yeah coming out
cuz they're so low on the suspension
Asgard you which I know that's kind of
what happens seems something like it
happens in like in the comics they go to
Arizona and they build the new house
cars I don't know mater right because
that's one one cool thing to me about
this too is that I've read the Infinity
Gauntlet comic a couple times but to me
this feels less like oh this is based on
a comic and more like this is an MCU
film actually that's what shouts out to
totally jumbled from the page strong
because that's I think I just took yes
when you get to you get to see fat Thor
right Big Lebowski Thor and I know some
people are a little bit you know
conflicted about how they feel about
this version of Thor
I get it some people think it's funny at
first but they thought he might go back
to being in shape like halfway through I
personally love it I love the choice
because five-year gap she's all the
guilt and regret afoot he just got a
little bit higher month for his head
because Rousso had talked about that
before this movie of how Thor feels
guilt over the the choice because of his
ego to just go for the the heart instead
of going for the head you know he wanted
that moment if he I just gone for the
head did none of this would happen yeah
so so he you understand why he is so
distraught and I and I do appreciate
it's like I get why you would be
conflicted about fat Thor for the
entirety of the film and for a few
minutes at least I was like
I bet he's gonna get buff again and also
minutes dad and and the thing is yeah I
like that they at least bothered to put
an emotional underpinning to that and
pay it off still so like it may clash
with the rest of the movie for some
people I can see that because the thing
is having fat Thor around makes him
always kind of funny later on in the
film you'll notice that they'll start
shooting him in certain ways to conceal
some of that laugh factor I think but
yeah I just it's a completely unexpected
detail that becomes its own little Side
Story and I did appreciate it and it
seemed within Thor's character or
especially with what they've been doing
with Thor lately the whole setup that
they have later on you shouldn't be
striving for you know who you're
supposed to supposed to be has to be the
best of who you are yeah you know and
because that's this whole conflict
within himself so it to me it's so in
tune with character and to me this is
the right way you subvert expectations
every moment of this this is how you
properly subvert expectations right yeah
and well yeah even the moment with like
Hulk and Thor because of how Hulk says
you know you saved me you help me out or
even even that little nugget of a moment
where Thor has his hand on oh yeah and
Hulk is just saying you know please take
please yeah yeah you know do something
yeah but he's being very kind about it
and then I I'm not sure exactly when
moment takes place but when they do get
to the the rump Hawkeye people keep
calling Hawkeye I call them Ronan Ronan
you feel like that's what the rendition
is when Oakland right Clint bar talk cuz
we get say a Clint fight that's probably
the first fight of the movie right from
you know unless you count them
restraining fan I was but not really you
know but that but that Hawkeye fight
that was a really cool fight yeah and I
love this the shots of just kind of
watching the reactions at moments oh
there's a beautiful one long yeah you
know uh great through the different
levels of the city really using the
colors of Tokyo and then I married John
with yeah and then when he has the
one-on-one fight with that that actor
who I've seen in a lot I thought in the
last
samurai is sunshine and a whole bunch
other things then that's all in one shot
to that whole fight and they got pretty
violent he cuts his throat they were
smart with the gore there because the
start bleeding a lot so he has his hand
yeah you don't see like a big slashed
throat yeah then he kills him and I love
that scene when him and him in a black
widow reunite of like please don't give
me hope this is such a personal if you
watch our first reactions that's all
I've ever wanted from this was I want
this to be the most personal Avengers
movie we've ever gotten and it's when
you look at an infinity war because it's
so jam-packed it is not as personal and
also Thanos his whole MO he says it
multiple times it's not personal and so
to have that contrast from infinity war
to this movie makes a lot of sense -
yeah hyper personal movie cuz yeah
everybody's story like there's action
but it's mostly about people's me a
little stakes so as movies like now
we're getting it's like more back to
territory as this movie sort of other
thing is really neat about this movie is
I feel like the others three acts and
each actors have like 40 to 40 to 45
minutes long and then you get like a
closing 20 minutes or something I don't
know I was looking at my phone and
timing it it just felt that way to me
right so when you get into the hole
alright we're gonna start having some
fun now no it's not just a [ __ ] that's
what I mean they really thought this out
about building it up let's up the first
act be really dark and sad and then
let's let's slowly get there that will
get to some hope elements now that we've
figured out the time travel stuff we've
got a plan
you know Toni calling for Lebowski well
I love that was an alright moment too
because you know they're the AHA crack
time-travel thing is a little hard to
sell in one scene but I thought the way
they handled that with Tony - was a nice
was a nice thing yeah and him you know
looking at the picture of Peter
remembering we have to make that
spider-man sequel and say what when they
start doing the time-travel stuff right
is there anything else for me
before we go into that I think that we
really need to touch on you know so when
they get to the time travel element that
was so cool I mean we we knew that there
would happen because we we had seen
those leaks set photos but even still
when you get to that moment I thought
the way they handle all of it was so
neat like all the time-travel stuff
definitely felt reminiscent him back to
the future to there's even a very
specific moment that I didn't realize
was like oh this moment is straight out
of Back to the Future to there when Tony
gets hit with the door
oh come the Hulk yeah that's what
happens with Marty McFly yeah yeah the
second time I watch them like oh that's
right hand it back to the future - I'm
going in a second right yeah which is
which I guess that's nice because they
call Back to the Future [ __ ] and
shots that's Andrew Gordon for say that
they're gonna be referencing that yeah
you pretty much knew that but what I
thought was neat about the way they
handled all that was more than just oh
look how cool it is we're revisiting
they use it to enhance the plot and in a
lot of ways it actually enhanced the the
some of the movies that we might have
even by Thor the dark world they kind of
made it better in a lot of ways yeah you
know with at least it yeah acknowledging
and tying them in and making them feel
bit more necessary that time travel
element I've never been the guy who
wants to binge watch series I'm like
we're gonna get another one or we're
getting in another one I don't feel like
binge watching he's every [ __ ] here
I've never wanted to be that guy I never
wanted not even for infinity war but
when we did that that made me suddenly
go I want to I want to start from the
beginning I want to see every little
nugget of Infinity stones that we've
ever heard of because now it's all
becoming complete right here every 10
years I want to do a Marvel to watch 22
movies yeah and so yeah you know like
there's a lot of ways that could have
handled it I like the different outsider
perspectives that you get from each one
of these moments where you're in the
2012 Avengers movie you see kind of like
oh here's how they handled the Loki
arrest yeah and so I mean I figure the
best way to talk about this just kind of
go one at a time yeah so with as cool
the dissenting to see that moment with
okey and like oh yeah there's that
moment where okay how do we handle what
we're gonna do with Loki yeah you know
in the tesseract yeah yeah and I thought
it was it was so cool to me how they
they disguise what would become an
essential plot point with Hulk you take
the stairs like it's just a funny moment
yeah just saying Hulk take the stairs
you see him going down the stairs later
in bitching about the stairs you think
it's just a funny thing that's not
really gonna factor in you know and you
know when Robert Redford shows back up I
thought that was great to see him there
you any of these little cameos that you
get was wonderful and then what Tony
gets a test writing like I was just
saying when he gets hit with the door
that's right out of Back to the Future
to lose a tesseract and of course Loki
takes the test Iraq yeah vanishes away
and maybe that's the Loki that's gonna
segue into whatever the Disney streaming
service shows gonna be for the guy okay
yeah I could see that and that could be
you know especially with the way they
lay out their time-travel dynamics I
think that would be appropriate yeah
yeah and the cap and Winter Soldier
callbacks when he gets in the elevator I
yeah everyone everyone in there was like
it both screenings were like oh sure
he's gonna and that's this movie in some
ways made me think of star trek into
darkness because I remember people
complaining distinctly about the way in
which they've mirrored moments from
Wrath of Khan and I really appreciated
the way that this movie would mirror
previous moments because I thought they
did it in a really nice kind of
alternate reality sort of way where it
was subtle but you know a nice nod as
well and it was cool because that was
also the Russo brothers first Marvel
movie - yeah and when he says like hail
Hydra instead of getting to a fight ah I
like it because you're showing that he's
using less you know you his brains along
yeah you know you well and in a mission
where you have to be as little as
possible
and even when he fights himself which
was really [ __ ] cool like cat versus
cap and you could see the growth of
Captain America to where he is now from
that moment and it's done to mean a
rather subtle way of what he goes I
could do this all day he's like I know
yeah or even when they're getting into
their fight which is a badass fight when
spirit of America future versus the
spirit of America when he gets when he's
able to win when he says he's alive
because showing that outlet you know of
how what's I don't know what the war
would be like feeling a little bit yeah
there's something I would at least cause
me to hesitate for a house yeah yeah no
he's using his smart with that joke
about think he's gonna say it yeah like
you don't notice that he's not looking
at it like the way they framed that shot
yeah great because you don't know that
oh that's the joke he's gonna say yeah
one and I appreciated that a lot of the
bits and oh modulus of this movie take
place in ways where you don't
necessarily know they're happening just
yet or you don't necessarily right
either they don't called only attention
to that it's like they're usually in the
midst of other things happening which is
nice and then with Thor going back to
Asgard I I it seems like Natalie Portman
showed back she was at the premiere
so she okay I was wondering if that was
like a deleted scene oh yeah they just
used a few shots from or if she had just
showed up to collect that Marvel money
but I was cool they Thor really got to
have a resolution with his mom with her
and he gets to kind of resolve at least
his feelings on James
well that and that also sets up the art
for where Thor's gonna land by the end
of this movie yeah because I've loved
how they recap Thor the dark world
because it's like they knew they don't
really like this movie but the way they
wreak it when Thor's like okay telling
this story making for Dark Elves
actually angry sludge somebody coded a
stone early that he starts getting more
sad it was like he's really good at
playing Thor's like strangely broken
confidence yeah um they say I having
that resolution I thought was mean and
even him getting immune or back that's a
pronounced but I think it's Mjolnir I
know how to spell it better than I know
how
pronounced uh mule near mule nor mMmmm
meal ticket meal ticket mmm um yeah
somebody gets that I'm still worthy and
you feel for it even though it's silly
it's like yeah so okay that's resolved
and then also then all I could think is
there's a Thor on this timeline who's
gonna be really pissed about it it's
sort of there they have to return all
the stones but should they return the
hammer oh maybe he does maybe cap takes
it bet he does I at the end of the movie
he does take the hammer back that's true
yeah and he can which was one of the
most surprising and then okay so before
we get to the nebula a moment but when
when Hawkeye and black widow Boromir
for me a dormir that place that looks
and sounds like a Lord of the Rings
place this to me I think this whole
sequence worked better the second time
I still kind I do have issues with it
when it leads up to the ultimate moment
yeah that's to me this is like I clearly
have close to close to zero issues with
this movie right but for me I think the
first time I watch it I just didn't buy
it until when everyone came back and I'm
like oh she really is dead yeah like
that that's what I was like oh nevermind
because I thought like I were gonna
solve this mission and she's gonna come
back so I don't really feel the weight
to this moment but even the second time
watching it because maybe because we did
that opening sketch that I had seen that
scene a gazillion times with Gomorrah in
order to try to get it down no Maya if
he made a 30 something minutes into here
I go check out our opening sketch so
when when you do get to that specific
moment it's it's kind of redoing that
it's redoing the thawing of more the
Fanus and gomorrah scene but you know
with different dynamics is you got
different characters in here yeah and I
think it was smart to have it be too
personal characters you
it was like you know rody and nebula it
won't work because not personal
yeah what do I have with me here that I
was felt like it was moving so fast
before it got to that moment tonight and
I could kind of get the conflict of the
editing and the writing of that because
you're like we already saw like the
setup of this in infinity war we can't
just redo it completely the whole
similar kind of setup cuz you're kind of
just moving fast past all these things
you know okay red skull's back that'd
I'd better die and I supposed to slow
down a bit when they're having a debate
of who should die you know and I really
appreciate the choreography of that
sequence and the way they scripted that
whole thing out where they're trying to
like out suicide each other the whole
time yeah yeah yeah and and well and
they take care to to make it so that
truly it does seem like in a sense
Hawkeye does let her go or I mean she
gives the kick but to have it be it
ultimately that it ends up he's holding
on to her he's tied to the cliff he
knows what's about to happen yeah and I
feel like that really drives that home
and rather than if one of them had just
jumped and no and while I thought the
acting was wonderful there and I really
their scene I started to feel for it
once it started going but I think just
because of how it led into it of how was
it was like very fast-paced that there
wasn't enough breathing room to really
settle into the fact that they're here I
just didn't really for some reason it
hits a lot of people I I know that but
for some reason it doesn't really hit me
I appreciate it it works but I don't
really feel for it exactly and I and for
me I think it's a couple of things I
mean there is the element of the fact
that I empathize with both them I like
both their performances but as
characters there are a lot of other
characters that I'm just more attached
to I know more about I've spent more
personal time with it's also the thing a
black widow of how she really hasn't got
her do yeah she has I feel like those
characters could have been more of
characters and that would have helped
but also too I I don't dislike the way
it is proportioned into the story but it
is one of the very few moments in this
movie that I think both times kind of I
was like when they showed back up I was
like oh that's right they're on a
mission to they're in this they're still
and then when they show back up that's
kind of the end for them yeah or at
least you know for Black Widow it's that
sequence and so it is this kind of this
iceberg out in the middle of the rest of
these things happening is cap and Tony
sure sure and so yeah I feel like maybe
certain things could have been removed
from that plotline a little bit to save
some time like maybe there was a little
more time on rocket ship in route to
Boromir
or something like that but yeah
ultimately it's like I liked everything
they included I just didn't feel a ton
of the impact yeah and so then you get
to like nebula and and Rhodey on the
guardians of name whatever that is one
of my favorite of different moments of
this where you see the same scene from a
different perspective
yeah when you when you cut because
you're back in the moment of star-lord
dancing and that awesome awesome
introduction of Chris Pratt in guardians
one having a great time but then you cut
away for it's a roadie and nebulas
perspective where he just looks silly I
thought that was really funny but I also
loved the way they toyed with the way
nebula works of how yeah it's like yeah
they setup that at this point in time
there's nebula and Gomorrah and Tana
it's all looking for the stone right now
but that I did not see that coming at
all of and it made sense for the way
nebula is programmed and by the way this
is the best nebula we've got what
nebulas memory server starts connecting
to old nebula you know yeah that was
that was one of those there a couple
times in this movie where plot elements
show up and you're like oh this is a
stretch but I thought they paid that off
pretty sure they do because you like you
you got rid of Thanos you're having all
this fun with a time-travel they're
handling business yeah and then oh yeah
and they have no idea that status has
been tinkering with his daughter and
make you some kind of cyborg you know
now we've got this shared network you
know and they have done such a great
distinct job of establishing like I
remember and Guardians one the nebula
was a villain yeah she was a bad guy and
then now she is a good person but even
but she said I even had some darkness
now whatever that she that's fun my
carny my Guardians won she was bad right
so having that old version of nebula not
being the understanding person or
whatever wanting to do the right thing I
do the good thing and just please her
dad made so much sense I like getting
back to like really tough warrior Kimura
yeah and so that plotline I thought was
really really really well done yeah
because that's that was such a clever
way to bring back Thanos so we can still
get the fans finale
oh they're surprised because a it's just
cool that sadly on the heels of what we
said about Hawkeye and black widow I was
surprised to how much I enjoyed seeing
Rhodey and nebula together and then yeah
once they kill thanos to the top you're
like I don't know exactly what his
presence is going to be in this movie
yeah to have like a fully you know like
seeing what's happened here in gating an
even better plan like yeah once things
started going to time-travel and [ __ ]
started to hit the fan like this you
just kept on doing things where I'm like
yeah let's let's mess up these plans and
make some risky choices yeah yeah really
make the stakes tangible you're like wow
we only get a few shots of this we only
got a couple Pym particles yeah and and
yeah that that too I guess because you
know this is the part of the plot where
everything kind of starts to go awry you
also have the bit with you know since
Tony everything went wrong he has to go
back and he and cap both have to go back
to the military base yeah I know and
break in there because they have another
idea of when the stones might have been
there and you get the great
foreshadowing of Peggy Carter yeah a
little moment with cap as well as the
run-in with Howard Stark you get to Stan
Lee cameo and who I thought was he's
gonna watch it like everyone applauded
I'm like what's Marc Maron good yeah WTF
just like Marc
the mustache yeah so um yeah that whole
thing I really do I thought it was great
when he when he does because he because
that's another thing with Tony that he
gets to have closure on is I love you
know like age of Ultron how joss whedon
was trying to mislead you with being
like he wanted to intentionally have you
think that what was cool here is that
they are setting up that Tony's journey
is going to be complete by the end of
this movie they are setting that up even
having his resolution with his father
which is we all know has been a very
very complicated relationship yeah so I
think that was so neat to have that in
here where they do have that resolution
is back to the future to like George
McFly Marty McFly you know having that
element there but some other dialogue
too I thought was great what what was
that exact line he's so neat when he
says like my dad gave me some pretty
good advice Oh something about no amount
of money ever bought a second time or
something like that yes yes cuz he does
have that line in there about I hope I
have a daughter Howard says that I hope
I have a daughter because I you know I
don't you wouldn't end up like me like
what's so bad about that and it's cool
to see that Tony has ultimately outgrown
who his dad even was like his dad was a
great guy but it says you know I never
did anything for the greater good you
know beyond myself or whatever and Jamie
has gone from being that guy to becoming
the total opposite yeah exactly the guy
Howard Stark maybe regrets not being
which is beautiful I mean sure we get
some cool little little nuggets of
cameos you see hank pym back there and
of course also within this time travel
element you do get I love that Tilda
Swinton came back for a significant role
some of these guys come back for just a
cool cameo but you do get what I like
what they did with the cameos other than
you know Robert Redford most of the care
I like Robert Redford's cameo but
characters like Thor's mom yeah or till
the Swinton these are characters who
have been killed off so they really gave
them a scene yeah yeah they gave them a
real moment
Shawn whereas like we know Hank Pym is
still alive he's fine and you see him at
the end he's fine so we don't need a
full-on scene with Hank Pym here but
let's give a full scene for an integral
moment to the ancient one and having
that element in there in the way they
discuss things too and her reasoning to
give the time stone over to Bruce Banner
I thought was really well done yeah as
well this movie bothers to have a lot of
debates about everything it's trying to
do yeah which is really smart in a day
and age of I mean and I know they said
this of their previous films you know of
honest trailers and pitch meetings and
things that really dissect your movie
heavily I feel like they're good at kind
of planning for those things and really
have these discussions walking around
inside these moments so when they get
you know then they get all the that
answers a plot hole to of like if this
order has been here what were they in
2020 you do see that she actually was
helping in the battle yeah yeah it
actually was fighting all these guitar
you ships and stuff and then when they
get back you know where they get all the
stones of the I don't know I think you
feel about them you know how you know
how I don't fini where they said that's
a whole set up about with the dwarves
and they had to build the gauntlets in
order to handle these stones and start
technology kind of hands along
convenient didn't bother me first time I
watched yeah I feel like they can easily
chalk that up to well Tony is just that
brittle like that's how they were able
to sell me the whole time travel moment
other than the way they handled it I'm
like well I know Tony's that brilliant
and I'm sure that yeah I think he needs
to create he'll figure but it's also not
perfect yes because like when Hulk uses
it you know he's like suffering with it
you know yeah and so I wonder I mean you
know you see it with Thanos and it does
roughly at least on the second snap the
same thing that it does to Hulk and so
yeah I did kind of wonder because it
seems like an infinity war they're like
no only an instrument forged in this
specific foundry our star juice and all
that stuff could handle the power of all
six stones and so like that I was on
tuna bone yeah a little bit but you know
but either way Hulk does the snap
nanotech um I love the way they handle
the return we'll go into it but they do
the snap right and if you look at the
way it plays out ant-man starts looking
outside seeing like the birds got a
beautiful out here life is returning and
then Clint gets a call from his wife on
a cell phone
yeah you're like it must have worked
right it must have worked and that shot
of light I think it's Hulk who's looking
up and he's seen looking through the
glass he just he's here because you know
nebulous of switching you just see this
missiles there's no audio beautiful yeah
and that was one little nitpick I had
both times was I was like I'm pretty
sure somebody would have died in this
attack Scott Lang would have died he's
got his helmet on well the second time
that would have blown up a second time I
watched I'd notice he instantly it's
kind of reflex for him to just hit that
button Oh does it come back yeah okay
yeah he hits the button okay so you seem
really really fast okay and I think they
kind of set that up
well when they first seemed like we only
got two test runs on this showing how
easy this time II NIF anyone Hawkeye
should have been the one who died and
then now we're in the epic act three
we're in the end game now where it's
like it's just been building and
building and building building and I
haven't I didn't watch any of this movie
going where's all the action it's so
grip I'm highs yeah it's got a whole
bunch of other stakes and tensions to
make you just yeah yeah it's so
character-driven and then um yeah it's
kind of cool to see that Oh nebula is
actually making daddy happy right now
yeah she's gaining favor she's being
cunning yeah and you see you see the
three characters I you see Iron Man
Captain America and Thor you know like
what's he doing there
yeah and I honestly I love when Thor you
know he decides to you know they do it
kill I love how he morphs into sort of
this like Viking look yeah yeah his
hairs a little different like the
overweight look works for the Viking
look for him it feels like very like
warriors yeah yeah I think teachers
somebody point out he looks like his uh
one of the guys on his team he looks
like the chubby guy yeah yeah yeah
who got kill off a Ragnarok yeah and
never know so yeah it has a very Viking
aesthetic to him but he's also wielding
both Stormbreaker he's wielding both of
those at the same time and when they
have that fight with him I mean it's a
it's a really great fight I did feel at
first that the stakes at first I felt
the stakes for a little bit lessened
because he doesn't have the gauntlet you
know you watch the first mover he has
the gauntlet you're like I'm fighting to
beat this guy when he has a golly you
know yeah you and he has a few stones he
does that all the stones and they're
fighting him on one you know an infinity
war when you have like Iron Man
spider-man and Starla are all going
after him but here it's like this is
just an older version of Fanus but what
was cool about he's got his big knife
you get us he got to see the warrior
side of Thanos here you can see why he's
scary anyway yeah like how he doesn't
need that gauntlet yeah awesome
because in infinity war all you get as
him versus Hulk yeah and then here
you're like oh you get a more of that
you know yeah I mean like they cut away
I think it's funny because when a lot of
the action scenes they cut to other
stuff when they take off but uh you get
that one really awesome like comic book
shot of you know why Tony jumps up
shoots some lasers at him you know the
cap and Thor they're all attacking him
at once and yeah it's very picturesque
it's great and you got the cool moments
with Hawkeye in the tunnel yeah Hawkeye
is so cool this movie yeah this is the
best Hawkeye I'm not sure like no
undoubtedly the best Hawkeye and of
course you know the freaking epic moment
in here which felt reminiscent of the
force awakens to me when really it's a
lightsaber but when this one it's set up
I love how they pay this they pay off so
much in here it's wonderful when good
cap gets it gets the hammer that was one
of the biggest cheer you both cannot
help but cheers because they've set up
they had the rewarding moment where Thor
gets his hammer back you have that
rewarding moment so you just you just
assume it's Thor's grabbing the hammer
right you just assume it um but then
when cap has it and then with Thor to go
I knew it's what we all like and that's
a great moment at least for me I was
like I was thinking that too I was like
I do because to me the most memorable
scene in all of age of Ultron is the gap
slightly moves it yeah I love how they
paid that off and the fact that he's
like switching cuz you get you get such
a cool mom you get Thor double wielding
with Stormbreaker yeah and in Hammer and
then you then you get cap with the
shield in the hamburger summons
lightning from the sky rate it's so cool
and it's so cathartic because of
everything that happened in the previous
movie and then the way he has gotten the
upper hand in this movie too you know
and then Rousseau's knowing like okay
someone's gonna die we all know one of
these makers gonna die all right and
then when cap loses you know half of a
shield is broken and you get this
beautiful epic shot that's like a
painting it's like that it's like some
of those shots that are a garage yeah
yeah
you see cap in the corner broken shield
and then just has his whole army coming
that's this crest of just daylight and
soot I cannot emphasize this enough the
way they handled the characters
returning it was so [ __ ] beautiful
and rewarding I can't emphasize it
enough because when when infinity war
happened and that decimation occurred
all of us were like well we know they're
all gonna come back it's not really big
and I was there I was I was in
conversation I was like as gonna be
cop-out maneuver how they do it you know
the Russos handled it so clever that i
completely forgot that they might all be
back you know it's like yeah they did
the birds and then someone gets a phone
call hawkeye gets the phone call
but when cap was looking out you're like
oh man there's no way can handle this is
like this is the end yes I'm came as far
as we could team I'm so in the moment
I'm like I have no idea how they're
gonna do this yeah and then cap come in
its Falcon yeah on your lip they made it
so rewarding it's more than just yeah we
knew this would happen you forget about
it you're so in the moment that when
they do it it's an emotional payoff when
black panther cherie black condors mom
when they when they all show up dude
with dr. Strange's the time yeah when he
when they show up man that brings tears
to my eyes it really does I'm so moved
by that moment and then they all start
showing up it's it's so it's funny to me
because it's so rewarding when they're
all show no star-lord flies inspire it's
so badass all over Conda shows up Baku
is in there I saw yeah everyone's
everyone everyone's there because an
infinity war you you have like most of
other than like ant-man and Hawkeye you
had at you yeah you have everyone there
but they're not all together you know
they're all separate spots we're here
they're all here I'll admit I got a
little distracted because I was so aware
of how so many people showed up to shoot
[ __ ] in front of green you have no idea
what they were shooting for there is a
certain element of characters are just
pop it up and you kind of get the sense
you guys weren't we're on the same stage
if you were here for an hour just to pop
up look around you had no idea how
there's a factory yeah
but that whole battle I mean it's a it's
a wonderful wonderful battle with a lot
of moments that really really stand out
to me it's like yeah you get the huge
calf you actually got to see Hulk
running and charging for the team you
know I mean I I love the like it was
that shot is in Civil War and a lot of
battle movies you know we're they're all
running after each other
but now they do that in sub or another
Russo brothers Marvel film at this time
on a much more epic scale and and with a
very different visual outcome because it
is so rewarding to watch as instead of
you know the advancing you know forces
overpowering them it's just our arrows
pushing them right back you know yeah
yeah and I even picked up for the second
time I watched it when something about
the gauntlet like the caps says
something like he says the word Queens
oh yeah yeah which is referencing to
Peter Parker yeah in Civil War when
they're like where are you from I love
that callback right there Valkyrie
riding her Pegasus Pegasus yeah and you
know you even when taking down that ship
and going through with this fear was
really [ __ ] cool you know you mean
captain morale
no no what she when she has like the
spear she's going she's taking down the
ship and so I make sure it's my
spider-man Oh him zipping through and
like getting help from everybody like
trying to carry the gauntlet but he says
like a kill mode or whatever that's
called
oh yeah activate kill huh yeah instant
kill mode because in in homecoming he
says and also a Spider Man reuniting
with Iron Man yeah that moment when they
hug each other it's so beautiful his
surrogate son yeah ibly inspired the
turn to having this family and in some
ways he's got a picture of it he's kept
the fit but he's kept the photo yeah and
you know that the loss of Peter is a
huge weight on his conscience for the
whole movie the most badass Scarlet
Witch moment in any of these movies yes
because she nearly kills him yeah cheap
again it's to the point where Thanos
penny
and he cuz cuz like my girlfriend is
obsessed with the Scarlet Witch
character is really hated the fact that
we never got to see the full potential
of her powers in any of these movies and
and that like Scarlet Witch could take
down Thanos and this movie shows you if
she was what I want with that oh so
there was no battleship would have won
no problem because when she's using her
full power and he starts freaking out
it's like he says like Hail Mary or
something
Oh hail fire yeah just drop by your
storm and then have any miles like the
troops like but really showing the full
extent of her powers is there any other
moments we're missing before Captain
Marvel shows up star-lord and Gamora
reuniting oh yeah she hits him in the in
the nutters again yeah good nugget of a
moment right there yeah yeah yeah and
and it kind of it does remind you of the
reality of the like Oh even though this
is a nice reunion the Gamora that
existed on this timeline is ostensibly
still not with us question mark we don't
know yeah that's true
and then when Captain Marvel shows up
when they else are shooting at something
in this guy like what are they shooting
yet yeah that's how [ __ ] cool I was a
great Captain Marvel yeah cuz they do a
great job of making the ship look so
huge and terrifying yeah then she just
flies through it a couple times and
really as like crucial and I loved I
actually really appreciate her
involvement in this movie because her
sparingly now they use her sparingly but
they use her insignificant moments that
make sense and that are appropriate I
think in the larger context because they
really don't hand this movie to her
because she is of the future phases I
mean you just even when you think she's
gonna be the thing that solves this
whole thing you think I mean she even
says you're not gonna see me for a while
and they they keep to that and I'm a
person who likes the Captain Marvel
movie but for this film I feel like her
involvement was really nice because it
was a significant
really all the characters we've been
with for ten years or the ones that we
are you know really giving all the
moments in the spotlights too so even
she is not the linchpin but she also
gets lead the ultimate feminism we're
all here yeah let's all charge together
all the women are I mean that they do
that in an infinity of war but that's
just three women this is every single
one this is every all the women here one
of them anyway that's one of those
things where you're like unlikely but
[ __ ] it's cool I understand who and
what this moment is for and for that I
appreciate it but yes this is very
handsome
I like female here I'm on both sides I'm
like I know it's ham-fisted
I they they know what's it for the
greater good I yes they know it's
ham-fisted but I'm totally cool with it
easy cool I love the exchange or like
Peter Parker so nervous to be around
Captain Marvel yeah
even weak at Marvel and Thanos are
fighting each other and I love that we
had so [ __ ] fun yeah a whole battle
was great and even even the little minor
exchange where Iron Man says like the
Doctor Strange like you said there was
one chance is it if I tell you you won't
happen this time I I thought it was a
Time Trial or the first time I thought
was like a time travel thing but then I
realized like the if I tell you what you
really gotta do this really might not it
might [ __ ] up you I mean that's that
choice also really quick I love how
Chris Evans actually said Avengers
Assemble actually makes sense in context
for that moment like you already are
charged
yeah you called what a good fanservice
yeah it was very
yeah but when when Thanos and Iron Man
do go toe-to-toe cuz you're like who's
you die here who's gonna die and when
Iron Man does tale it's really well
handled because Thanos does a snap and
it just clinks yeah well and I love the
lead-up to that too because it reminded
me it's another one of those mirror
moments where in infinity war it's like
caps got the gauntlet and then this one
Captain Marvel has the gauntlet trying
to stop it and then he had Tony jumps in
and that whole ruse I thought was really
nice especially in the way they time it
out yeah
because he's he's got his hand on the
glove and you know all that and it was
perfect I never saw it coming with you
know of course Tony has a backup what
you didn't know
okay really quick backtracking just a
tad bit try remember month ah here oh
yeah with Thanos the whole I am
inevitable thing because before Ironman
says his final line oh and he says I am
inevitable the second time I watch it I
really picked up on it of that theme of
Thanos in here because they kill off
Thanos in the beginning of this movie in
time and yet he still comes back we
retrieve his stuff yeah it's like no
matter what they do it's inevitable
they're gonna go toe-to-toe with this
guy when it comes to these stones you
know I love that running theme and also
the way he does like when Tony is
accepting his his sacrifice moment cuz
before that yeah it's really cool when I
forget the name of whatever the Gwyneth
Paltrow version of Iron Man is Pepper
Potts version I forget the specific name
of it
something with an R I think whatever
that was cool
some people question like how did she
get a handle on like well it's been five
years maybe she's like [ __ ] around
like five years maybe she secret around
with it at some point right is where
we're capping a lot of stuff here we're
paying some sentimental moments of when
he went when Iron Man does the way he
says it like accepting his full
completion of this character I
snaps everyone starts estimating away
from the 2014 timeline I love how Thanos
sits down sits down accepting failure
yeah he's accepting his failure and he
slowly gets to decimate away which was
cool yeah
maybe Tony did think that I want him to
go last really laughs and I wasn't sure
what would happen to Tony you know I'm
like maybe he's fine but then when you
see how burnt up he is you know like oh
damn now he's they let you figure that
he's [ __ ] and the main people get to
say goodbye to him he can start off with
Rhodey his best buddy Rhodey gets to say
goodbye to him first or like I was like
worried about him there's a reversal
with spider-man and Tony as opposed to
infinity war you get the reversal there
when I cry both yeah think about the
time when I cry cuz both times I've seen
I don't really tear up at that moment
but at the time when I [ __ ] and start
the ball is when pepper checks like the
vitals of a suit realize he's gonna die
yeah okay goes and says we're okay now
you can rest oh [ __ ] okay we can rest
every time and that happens where she's
like I'm not gonna cheer up I'm gonna
wait I'm gonna wait I'm gonna wait I
want him to just rest now right there oh
man I start [ __ ] bawling he dies and
she starts I'm ball times I'm a wreck
when I watched that scene yeah like that
was that was like the most beautiful way
to handle the death I love how the the
last line of Iron Man 1 is I am Iron Man
his last line here other than the
message that he leaves for his daughter
his last living line is I am Iron Man
here so it's a great completion of his
character that is really [ __ ] them
works perfectly Hannah perfectly handled
and it's it's well timed it has all the
impact you want it to and the subsequent
funeral as well you know yeah we're all
the characters but no you would even
have
backing shot I've been having on the
lake of Tony Stewart does have a heart
yeah yeah beg harkening back to par one
yeah that pepper gave him and then yeah
and then you're coming to all the people
women hang in being there who never
really likes target yeah yeah one you
know like Black Panthers there and even
the little boy from Iron Man final break
it is there yeah sexy that was wonderful
his goodbye to his daughter I thought
was Britt wonder if they'll ever I mean
going to Paltrow said she's done with
the Frank who would the MCU but maybe
she'll come back it's too bad everyone
has an option to return some it's it's
crazy because Iron Man dying has been
teased so many times Avengers Assemble
freakin Captain America Civil War even
war so many moments that he's gonna die
banned like how he did he's willing to
sacrifice himself and here after he's
completed his full selfless art he does
ultimately sacrifice himself for
everyone and I love that his motive was
I don't want to change the timeline I
just want to bring people back yeah - oh
I just want to bring them all back I'm
here which I I thought was beautiful
because he was through what it had the
most intent he's the one who figured
this out he's the one who was the last
one who wanted to do any of this but he
did it for the greater good just like
how his father said he you know like his
father wouldn't do that and he showed he
how grow he I grew up I like beautiful
it's hard as [ __ ] for me to imagine this
franchise without Tony Stark and I mean
a long time ago I did say like he has to
die like it's if they're gonna complete
this he has to die
and I respect them for killing him off
it is very difficult for me to imagine
him not being in this franchise but what
a way to go and Robert Downey jr. is
financially set for life Sherlock Holmes
three off the ground then you get the
coda with cap with cap taking back all
the stones and stuff like that and what
he talked about
courtesy yeah that was great because I
love how I love how you know Tony dies
but cap cap doesn't die they gave those
virginity that's what they should have
cut back throughout the year yeah I mean
yeah I didn't I I didn't pick up a ton
the first time that Bucky knew what cap
was gonna do but the second time I
watched it beta tends to the dialogue
when Bucky does say I'm gonna miss you
man yeah I'm like oh he flat out knows
that he knows his plan I think cap ran
it by him oh yeah so we cap does a
certain cap shows up as looking like
Clint Eastwood yeah it was interesting
because I wondered a lot about how they
achieved that effect because it looked
like some combination of like makeup and
old aging yeah yeah and I almost
wondered if if maybe they did some like
stitching like put his face on too like
an old guy's body but in a makeup but
then that was assisted by scene it was
weird it was like in some ways I liked
it better than some of the d aging
although I still noticed it was some
sort of effect but I liked old cap and I
like the way he the mannerisms and the
voice and all that yeah and I love how
he gave the shield to Sam - Sam yeah
demo which is kind of I mean it makes
you wonder about the future of like
whatever did I got her there doing that
you know Falcon and Bucky show and you
and I thought they were always setting
up for Bucky to be Captain America the
thing is that with Sam as Captain
America he doesn't have any superpowers
yeah where's Captain America often
relies on his ability to for up super
strength and achieve all these things
that got you kind of have to have this
level I don't know the comics of that to
that degree to know like once if Sam is
Captain America like how he does it does
he get some serve injection or something
I don't know but I still think it was a
cool handoff and bottom line it's more
than focusing on
the handoff to Sam it's the send-off of
Captain America and that was really what
I was hoping for I mean it's funny going
into this movie I was expecting the
opposite thing to happen we're like okay
I would expect that Tony will retire so
that he can come back whenever he wants
but he doesn't have to be here and then
Captain America will sacrifice himself
or something like that and I really
loved that that they switched it and
that cab gets to go back and gets to
just have a life with his love and after
all of this time fighting and
sacrificing yeah I mean honestly I would
have been I probably would have been a
little upset if cap sacrificed himself
because I have always joked about how
he's never gonna just enjoy his life
yeah and Tony very much as like he he
gets these powers he's in the ice
forever he just goes right back to being
Captain America's super soldier I don't
think he's ever lost his virginity like
he's ever gotta have a date like none of
that and he's always been hung up on the
same woman for all these years the love
of his life
and he's not at this time he's not at
this time and then he gets to go back
and and course-correct his own time his
own life yeah which I thought which I
thought was beautiful I know some people
get confused off timeline stuff but you
know without really going into that I
thought for as a send-off to this
version of Captain America I thought it
was beautiful absolutely this movie hit
all the right marks even even being like
not I want to tell you about who this
woman is that I married you think going
back to the past and watch them having
to dance dance full circle man [ __ ]
brilliant
and that post-credit scene oh yeah with
the clanging with the with the pounding
metal sound which at least mr. Sunday
movies theorized was perhaps a nod to
the original Iron Man when he's pounding
the metal sheets okay yeah yeah but who
knows man maybe there's so much that we
can decode from this and we just don't
know it yet that's funny because you
serve the MCU it's all gonna be sound
it's no visuals I'd love that there's no
post-credit scene III I'm like no there
shouldn't be it feels entirely
appropriate to me it's the closing of a
chapter press screening no one was upset
opening night Wow people were like mad
you're like all these people and I'm
like is that there was no post credit
scene and in that moment I did kind of
get why people will be mad because the
post credit thing is such a signature of
the MCU started with the first Iron Man
movie that I can actually I can actually
understand if you are mad that there's
not anything it literally could have
done anything you could have had you
could have put a joke we could have done
you but whatever you know you you know
how like in Logan with yeah Logan it's
just the X of the the symbol of Logan
above the grave yeah
like if they did something like that you
know I don't know you hear doin anything
could've been like an image or something
it's the top of Tony's casket and then
the particles start to lift off a little
bit Rick you didn't like an image or
just Stanley posing with the whole cast
or whatever that would have been you
could've done anything as it stands I
get if you're upset because of
everything are just acknowledged at the
same time I think it's totally
appropriate that we didn't have anything
because this is supposed to close an end
so it's totally fine
anywho we have covered all of vendors
and Gailey broken this movie down yeah I
love this movie if you happen to stay to
the end what is your favorite part of
Avengers endgame thank you if you stuck
around this whole time yeah where would
you rank this cuz it's personally my
favorite movie this is the most time
we've dedicated to any Marvel movie for
that purpose yeah you guys can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell and go ahead check us
out on patreon
we're done and the amino app I mean our
give me this watch this video thank you
guys for sponsoring this video